hey welcome back to the samuel and
amanda show
i'm samuel and i'm amanda and we're
gonna be talking about money
marriage and life so what have you been
up to this week
this week's been a good week and i've
been potty training ruby
and that's really success although she
was she kind of got an age whereby
she's so old now yeah that to potty
training you kind of just go
from now on ruby you want to use the
potty and she's like all right yeah i
know she took to it so well
so yeah i think she's definitely old
enough i feel like maybe because she's
our first i kind of babied her a bit
more
yeah so i didn't realize that she
actually probably could have started a
bit sooner than
she has she's three years old so that's
your week an entire week
i mean yeah and then i've just been
doing like boring stuff like admin
sorting out gases what about when you
sorted out all that property stuff for
the product
oh my gosh so yesterday i was going
through a legal pack
for a property that we were buying yeah
and samuel hadn't told me that
we actually weren't going ahead with it
and i just i literally went through
everything it written down my queries
for anything that i wanted to ask the
solicitor
only for samuel to say after i said i
needed to sign a few bits and i was just
like oh yeah that house which by the way
so sorry about that basically yeah
amanda deals with not only the property
management and overseeing but also all
the sales progressions
and things yeah so great and i've been
well today i have been with ricky who is
an incredible guy we've been hanging out
and also i've just been giving him some
tips on
a lot of our students that become
financially free
they think when they become financially
free they just want to line the beach
you know they do oh whenever i'm
financially free i'm gonna line a beach
and just chill out and do nothing but
actually when they become financially
free they want to set up charities
they want to become a trainer and that's
ricky he's a trainer
he's one of our one of our trainers and
yes i've been spending some time with
him he's amazing isn't he yes and also
we are looking to rent another house
in buckinghamshire you know we do rent
a few houses because it's nice to kind
of household a little bit
yeah household a little bit in fact
that's one of the big advantages to
renting
i feel like honestly like being able to
just
move house easily it's just great and
also the rent that we pay on our
big houses yeah i'll just say mansions
but that sounds a little bit
oh i don't mention they'll be i don't
know what the difference what the actual
definition of a mansion is i'm not quite
sure but
are we are we in a mansion i'm not sure
i mean it's a big i would have
definitely called it a mansion when i
was a kid
yeah but who knows what a mansion is i
think there's different definitions
depending on who you're speaking to
um but anyway so we are
yeah i just went on a little walk
literally down the road from here with
ricky
but i didn't tell ricky that we were
going to be doing house viewing i just
started to walk and then we ended up
going to this beautiful big house
he's like oh my goodness so uh yeah
we'll say
we might rent it do some business and
yeah i mean the rent's so cheap so
that's what i've been doing
nice sounds like a good so we've got
we've had some we had some
lots of lots of questions from the guys
um
so from you guys and by the way if you
haven't watched my phone if you
would like to hear like behind the
scenes inside life
what's what just comment on this channel
you know if you want to learn about
the in-depth property niche things then
you can check out tomorrow's video q a
sunday
um okay so someone said
yeah okay let's get into it then okay
awesome someone said i love amanda
lisa's
accent oh so tell me about it thank you
my accent i'm from leeds
so originally zimbabwe moved to leeds
when i was 10 years old and then i guess
that's my accent it was one of the
things that actually kind of hooked me
when we first met i
you know you looked when we first met
very
zimbabwean right i mean
you had really short hair okay you know
such a little thing you just looked
there it was it was it was an african
wedding
okay you know yeah but then when we
spoke and you had a really strong
yorkshire accent it was just like
what it didn't look like it was supposed
to come out of your mouth yeah
now of course very very used to it but
um so yeah yorkshire accident moved to
england when you were 10.
yeah do you think do you what do you
think i'll talk to margaret about this
this morning
when you move to an area like i know
people that moved to america when they
were 15
and now they're like in the 20s but
they've got an american accent i'm like
come on you missed it when you're 15. i
don't know
i don't know um i think i think it's
natural to catch a bit of them
i know the people that moved to england
when they were like six
from america yeah and they've still got
an american accent
so it's so weird i don't know did you
choose did you choose to have a
yorkshire accent did you kind of
lean into it i like this
like how you speak so if you want to
sound like a bit of a i was going to say
chav
if you want to sound a bit like i don't
know
i don't know i think you can choose how
you want to speak but i don't think you
can choose
when i grew up yeah i mean my accent i'm
from
the midlands so i might have a midlands
twang
i don't feel like you do go on but when
i grew up at school
a lot of people that i was around my
friends but you know they spoke like
this really
slow and had an accent they did
and i didn't like the accent and i made
a deliberate effort i was like i don't
want to speak like that wow
interesting and that was that was where
i was from i grew up in you know warsaw
wolverhampton
and i'm not saying that i'm well spoken
you know
i'm not well spoken
and even as a kid even though everybody
around me like that
yeah i was just like nope that's
i don't interesting because about things
like that so for me it's just my
accent's just happening but when you
move to the auction you must have
noticed that suddenly
instead of people saying no they were
saying no no because the thing is
because when i moved from zimbabwe it
was like yeah everything was different
so it wasn't that are you listening to
it i mean maybe you can say that but i
don't
so like is your your accent would you
say it's like a little bit of a put on
accent no it's not because
it's not it's not because that's just
how i speak
and i can't speak any other way unless i
do an american accent which is like
oh my gosh you know
yeah you probably shouldn't do that very
often i think i'm very good at an
american
yeah okay all right next um sam
hague says tell us about your christian
faith sometimes how it influences your
approach
to business you wanna ask the first
storm
yeah i mean listen i i've always been
very open about it it's funny because
the more
and more well-known i've been getting
how often do i get told by our advisors
our solicitors and business consultants
everybody says
don't talk about your faith right yeah
constant
that's what i've heard for the last four
years um
they also say don't talk about politics
don't talk about politics they're
talking about religion off
the table i've never found like
for me i don't know i think people say
that because if you talk about your
faith
you might alienate people that are of a
different faith or who are off no faith
but do you think you can do it in an
alienating way
like for me my faith is everything okay
you can you can check out my books
and youtube videos where i talk about i
started my business
i became a christian when i was 16 got
plugged into a local church
my church sent me off on a trip to
zambia which is which is right next to
the best country in africa
um and you know it was actually that
trip
where i i saw young kids that didn't
have clean drinking water and i'm just
thinking man
if if i ever become wealthy i'm gonna
set up a charity and i'm gonna bring
clean water to this village
and it was kind of like really my my
faith my purpose my why i set my
business up i didn't set it up just for
the sake of it
and then as i started making money we
set up the the um
you know you came out with me on one of
our early trips in 2014 2015.
so like six seven years ago just as we
first got together and um
you know so my faith is a fundamental
foundation to to everything that i do um
i'm not afraid to talk about it um
politics sometimes i wonder whether i
shouldn't
i think personally i think you shouldn't
yeah um
i think that so i think by the way just
for the record i'm not super political
anyway yeah yeah you know i'm not like
really into politics
but go on what do you think you should
talk about i think i think religion's
different
um because you the way you do it for
example doesn't force it onto anyone you
just sort of share
your faith and you know what it is
people ask me i'm open about it
yeah but i think when it gets political
i think it's just a bit too contentious
because people
are different and i don't know i just
feel like it's just something that
unless you're a politician and in that
line i don't think anyone really
needs to speak out again about it but
the problem with talking about politics
is that people can misunderstand
sometimes i have to talk about politics
yeah
like my recent debates on the rent
control
it is a political issue but it's also
completely
an economic issue as well like rent
control in london rent
control that's about property i have to
have an opinion i can't yeah i can't
just say nothing on it
yeah people are asking me about it what
do you think i have to say i don't think
it's a good idea
here's why it's not a good idea i talk
about it it is political
um okay so maybe i think it's when
so if it's like political and it's kind
of linked to property fair enough but i
think it was
just something that's totally unrelated
and something that
might actually cause a stir
unnecessarily where it's like you really
don't need to speak on it publicly
then i think then you know it's kind of
like just stay in your lane type thing
i don't know i don't know if i grew up
staying your name stay in your lane
can keep people pigeonholed yeah and
it's a really tough one i mean something
that my pastor says to me gary spicer
she says don't die on the wrong mountain
so what that means is if something's
like really important to you you're like
i have to talk about this this issue for
me is so important and so big
if i die on this mountain i'll i'll
happily die on this mountain okay this
is
fine but don't die climbing mountains
that you don't need to be climbing yeah
you know so in other words if you talk
about politics
religion whatever you might die you know
they're gonna come for you
right they're gonna come for you whether
that be the media whether that be
the trolls they're gonna come for you
and they might
finish you off so if you just talk about
something that's not
really even that deep it's not that
important
it's not that linked you're not that
passionate about it but you just have an
opinion and you just
start shouting your mouth off about it
and then you die
as a result of your career dying why did
i die on that mountain
whereas some things are really important
but i also think the reason that you
might die on the mountain
because because it's crazy that we we do
get killed
talking about i'm not talking literally
although sometimes
you do die literally but it's crazy that
people do come after you the media and
whoever
because my opinion is let's just agree
to disagree let's debate
let's discuss let's talk about politics
religion
that's how we grow let's talk about
economics but let's learn from one
another
and most people are actually good people
so it's a lot of misunderstandings going
on like the rent control thing i'll say
rents should not be capped people assume
what i mean by that is
stuff the tenants yeah i'm not saying
stop the tenants
so it's almost like the the um there's a
lot of things that i could say about
politics i could share my opinion
but people would misunderstand my actual
heart i think that's the theme i think
that's the thing
so if someone knows you personally and
you say something
we know where you're coming from but if
they don't know you personally when
you're like
so well known then that's where it can
cause issues i think so but religion is
something my faith is something that i
always talk about because it's
i'll i'll die on that mountain if i get
persecuted and i have
you know german license took the mick
out of me like crazy a lot of people
have been really badly persecuted right
because of my faith but i don't really
care i'm just like whatever
uh it's a mountain i'll happily die on
but there's some things
that amanda won't let me talk about yeah
yeah what was the question did we
actually answer it
yeah tell us about your christian faith
sometimes and how that influences your
approach to business
kind of i think we just just ended up
talking anyway what do you think though
like because honestly part of me does
sometimes think i'll be better off
just talk freely and openly about
whatever i want to talk about
she doesn't look great i don't agree i
think there's a time and a place
people are going to be interested by the
way it's not like there's anything in
particular that i'm like itching to say
in general like if something happens in
the news if
someone becomes a prime minister things
gonna i obviously have an opinion on it
right i'm studying
i'm looking and i'm watching but then
often i won't talk about it
just because you know i don't want to go
on the wrong mountain
i don't want to get in trouble with mrs
leeds
okay next amanda how do you overcome
procrastination
i'm sure we had that question before i'm
not sure if we have
okay well go ahead how do you overcome
procrastination i don't know i just
just do it procrastinating just waits
wastes time
or do you not have a problem with it
because you just enjoy getting
procrastinated
is that how you live your life being
procrastinated no i'm just kidding
you're you you you are right yeah yeah
yeah you get stuck just
do it like just do it like you do get
some stuff done
you're quite quick at getting stuff done
yeah do you not have when you've got to
get something done
let's say we're buying a property you've
got to get sales progression which takes
forever
and you've got a lot of stuff do you not
find that you've got
those ping messages and things happening
how do you how do you deal with that
have you got a technique that you could
share oh
well um i don't know i just do a list
like i said last time so kind of
answered it before
just do a list and then just prioritize
and then just
do it and sometimes i do do like if
there's something that i really don't
want to do
i just kind of do that first and then
it's just out of the way yeah otherwise
it's just like a black cloud that's just
following you everywhere and i hate that
feeling
do i ever experience it procrastination
i actually do sometimes i had a real
severe
um dose of procrastination the last few
days
oh man don't worry absolutely bad
girl i'm really bad normally things that
i would
okay if i'm procrastinated if i've got
to do this but i keep doing all the
other things
it's because i don't want to do this
yeah no if i don't want to do this
i just outsource it right i just pass it
to somebody else to do and say how this
i think if you're not doing what you
love doing it's probably because you're
not meant to be doing it not always most
of the time
however i'll tell the story i don't tell
you this because i've
almost passed it to you or someone but
no one would have been able to do it
so what happened was i ordered some
books i had some books ordered for
the the 30 success students yeah i told
the 36s students
that i was going to send them all a copy
of the book
they were no thank you however i didn't
want to send them like a pdf version or
kindle i need to give them a proper hard
nice copy signed
perfect yeah i ordered a cop some copies
they came but
they were the text wasn't justified
properly because you pointed it out
right
so i reordered the books but they were
going to take a couple weeks
and i just thought all my students are
going to be saying
where's my book at yeah so i did a
youtube video
i i just for the 30 people where i was
just saying hey guys the book's gonna be
a little late this is what happened blah
blah blah blah
did it and i thought i'd just send it to
them all but for some reason
there was a blockage where i couldn't
send everybody the video
i don't know what it was why i think
it's because some of them i was talking
to on what's that saw on facebook
someone
instagram i wanted it to come personally
from me
and i just i just couldn't i don't know
it wasn't because i didn't want to do it
i think i just couldn't
bring myself to finding the time and
messing around and finding their names
and
i was just like oh and i kept putting it
off and putting in half
yeah so i do deal i do suffer sometimes
with procrastination
i did it in the end of this morning i
was just like you know what and you know
what just do it it took me
10 minutes yeah i thought i've been
putting this off for two days
even though it's just an easy simple job
but it's like a black cloud isn't it
yeah
so that thing that you're
procrastinating learn from me just
do it do it just do it okay next
question
um would employing a private driver
be worth it for you while they drive you
you can sit in the back and be more
focused on the business via phone calls
emails and other work tasks over the
internet
that's very interesting i think you
could benefit from a driver and i've
said this before
i just love driving samuel loves driving
but i do feel like he'd be really really
um productive if you would think i don't
want to because if i'm sat in the back
on my phone i'll get carsick
yeah that's the thing that's the thing i
guess if i'm driving
it's beautiful peaceful thinking time
massage
with the chairs massage me although my
massage chair just broke
so we ordered a new massager from inside
the uh the car
but i love driving i did have a driver
when i got banned
yeah and a driver brian drove me around
for six months it was nice i love brian
but i don't know i just like driving i
think i think at some point
he's here's what my dream would be yeah
my dream would be
to have a car that had such a big back
entry or a caravan attached onto it
where i could just lie down
camera bag but then i would should drive
i'd have a driver
oh right okay so you'd wanna you'd wanna
i'd have a driver
but as long as i could literally not
just be able to lie down
people oh you put your seat back no no
no it's not the same
i'd like to have like a proper bed
where i could lie down well that sounds
like a tour bus type situation
there we go yeah but when would you need
a tour bus or something
no i mean if i was just like like
tonight here today but tonight i'm going
to
where am i going tonight leagues right
it's like a four-hour journey
i've got a coaching call tonight at
eight and i'm thinking oh man
i just got but i'll just leave at 10 p.m
i'll lie down relax get some work done
have a little senior
that would be nice get there i don't
know two in the morning and just go
straight to my hotel
oh okay that's my dream oh i can make
that happen
really yeah yeah okay that is my dream
all right next i love oh i've
had that one okay next okay here we go
um
hi manual samuel i hope you're both
doing well i have a question for you
both how do you grow
your positivity and be more positive in
life
do you ever experience depression in any
points of your life
and career whilst chasing your goals and
how did you get out of that depressed
mood who asked that question
yeah oh yeah okay so
it's an interesting question because i
think naturally i'm just
a positive person i'm very optimistic
and i always
focus on the positive naturally um
so my tip for how to stay positive is
just to focus on the good
yeah and simply that focus on the good
so even when things are going bad
just think focus on what's good in that
situation because i think
in any situation and you know bad things
can happen
but what's good you know if sometimes if
you feel like you're really really
challenged usually from that challenge
you're gonna grow and learn from it
so i'd focus on that and not the actual
problem at hand
you know i agree i mean i've never had
depression i've never suffered with
depression i don't think you have either
no um however
i mean you ask about have you been in a
depressed mood
i mean i think that's probably a very
different thing i think being in a in a
bad mood
have i been in a bad mood yes i mean
i'm in a bad mood right now because i
need a haircut
damn i need a haircut bad amanda's the
good thing about lockdown is you haven't
learned to cut my hair though yeah you
know what it's funny because you
used to cut my hair through lockdown it
was great but now we're technically out
of luck now in a bit
i think hairdressers are open so i'm
thinking our hairdressers are open
but i don't want to go to the
hairdresser because i'm i'm not
i just know i'm gonna they're gonna be
awkward yeah social distance wear a mask
even though they're open i can't really
i can't be bothered with all the red
tape so i'm kind of
now i'm just doing nothing and now
suffering with with flat long hair so
i think i'm just gonna have to make the
decision am i gonna go
i don't think
and she's going to get me a caravan on
the back of a driver's car
you heard it you know you heard it um
last time i can remember being in
a really bad mood was actually quite
recently
remember no go on
i cried oh my gosh
okay i didn't actually cry well okay he
did have tears okay
that was nothing to do with the actual
yeah right are you joking
i actually genuinely think you were just
quite emotional oh come on
okay so sounds ridiculous okay samuel
wears a belt with his trousers or his
jeans or whatever
anyway he have to of course your
trousers fall down okay
he's not like a choice he have to have
to wear a balcony
okay but he frequently loses his belt
okay and then asks me where the bell is
i'm like
i don't know it's your bell i don't know
where you put it
yeah so the other day over the weekend
he was like oh
where's my belt where's my belt i don't
know i helped him look couldn't find his
belt anyway he has a few belts he has
three belts at least i know off
couldn't find any of these three belts
anywhere around the house
so he you weren't happy with it i was so
annoyed because i was annoyed not with
amanda i was annoyed at the situation
yes
because i often can't find a belt and
i'm like
i have three belts i can't find any of
them not in the car and i'm in the house
and i must be like 10 minutes looking
for a belt and i just thought what a
waste of time and i i wouldn't have been
so annoyed but it happens regularly and
i said to amanda
i'm going to spend like an hour a month
looking for a valerie what a ridiculous
waste of time so um i think amanda you
know i'm not happy
and i want ten belts you know ten bucks
she said
i want ten belts and when i lose a
couple belts i want you to just order me
an extra couple belts
you know so i'm never in this whole
situation i wasn't crying without me in
the car and then i had hay fever and my
eyes got a bit watery and there was an
air con
there was air like you know when the air
comes whacking your face it was like the
hay people on the air come together
didn't make me teary eyed
but it had nothing to do with the belts
okay anyway he's now got ten belts yes
you did all the way ten belts there we
go i'm wearing one right now
so um yeah i'm wearing one more last
time you're in a bad mood
yeah so to answer your question have i
ever been depressed no
but do i ever get in a bad mood yes what
do you do about it
have a rant have a beautiful partner who
can
listen to your rap i was gracious i just
listened to it be gracious and then
order you ten belt the same story if a
man is in a bad mood
i'm gracious to amanda that doesn't
happen very often
um if i'm in a bad mood because again a
lot of couples
slip into the marriage advice right now
what happens is
things escalate right imagine we've
already been like wow
and amanda would have gone well you lost
it what am i
it would have made me probably i wanted
but but i didn't start having a big
argument
whereas our rule is if one person's
unreasonable
or irritable or whatever be gracious
love them through it yeah fix the
problem
and then if if they were really bad you
can always bring it up the following day
in the cold live day yeah when they're
not in a bad mood and just say
hey look man you know yesterday that
whole belt thing yeah you were a dick
you know i mean that's unreasonable what
what are we gonna let's talk about it
it doesn't really happen very often but
but that's the thing to do
not in the heat of the moment yeah wait
until you've got 10 belts before you
have the conversation
and uh that's my top marine advice but
that's from me
amanda what top marriage advice
final words of wisdom final words
or top marriage advice whatever okay
actually i just did an instagram post so
i can
say which had some words of wisdom um
it said it was a quote that said worry
never took away
net worry never takes away tomorrow's
troubles it takes away today's piece
which i thought was quite profound and
good because yeah
worrying is just like such a waste of
time
like it's never solved any problems
that's true um
and it is true it takes away today's
peace so that's my final words of wisdom
don't worry about anything what about
plastic on there
i don't know please i wondered what you
were doing
i was just trying to find out where my
pasta has gone but we probably just fell
off when you're in the shower
maybe maybe that's great advice done
don't worry about
about about the little things and also i
mean because i'm a christian
there's a verse in the bible that says
um don't worry about anything
pray about everything and so if you're a
christian let's say
that's what i'd advise because um you
know you get a sense of peace
even even though like if you pray it
might not solve the situation like that
but you have that sense of fear yeah one
of the things that you know talking to
prayer people are thinking what are you
doing prayer about everything
um you know one of the things i do often
when i pray is i actually just
thank god for my blessings and whether
you're a christian or not a christian
you can still be thankful and grateful
and just spend some time to have some
gratitude
for the good things you've got in life
because what you focus on
expands yeah so if you focus on the
problem if you're in debt
and you're like thinking about the debt
don't focus on the debt
be grateful for what you've got and
focus on the solution you know so um
great stuff great advice and i look
forward to seeing you guys next time
subscribe
put your comments below if you've got
questions comments or
me or amanda and we look forward to
seeing you next time on the samuel and
amanda show
money marriage and life